the 2020 election saw many billionaires
use their money to influence elections
and ballot measures
and while the presidential election took
days to call by thursday
a handful of clear billionaire winners
and losers emerged
one of those winners was jim justice the
west virginia billionaire won a second
term as governor of the state
after raising 1.8 million dollars and
loaning himself
two million dollars sheldon adelson also
came out on top on election night
the gop mega donor pumped 60 million
dollars into the senate leadership
fund a super pac supporting republican
senators
he also gave one million dollars to a
super pac supporting the re-election of
lindsey graham
who handily beat jamie harrison who
himself
raised an eye-popping 109 million
dollars
election day losers include michael
bloomberg and kanye west
bloomberg spent 1.1 billion dollars of
his own fortune on his presidential
campaign
which he shut down after earning only
one win on super tuesday
west's own failed campaign backed by 10
million dollars of his own fortune
was only able to garner about 60 000
votes in a handful of states as of
wednesday morning
california ballot initiatives also
attracted a ton of money
proposition 20 which would have made it
more difficult for convicted felons to
qualify for early parole
was being fought by netflix ceo reed
hastings wife
patty quillen and facebook ceo mark
zuckerberg
quillen gave two million dollars while
zuckerberg's chan zuckerberg initiative
put nearly 2.3
million dollars behind defeating the
proposition which has been rejected by
voters
quillen gave another quarter million to
support proposition 17.
this ballot measure which passed gives
parolees in the state the right to vote
but not all ballot measure donations
paid off for donors
zuckerberg's philanthropy organization
spent 14.6 million dollars to support
proposition 15
which would have increased property
taxes on businesses to raise
billions for schools and local
government this ballot measure was
defeated
proposition 16 which failed would have
repealed the state's ban on affirmative
action
quillen supported the initiative to the
tune of 1 million
former microsoft executive steve ballmer
and his wife also gave a million dollars
to the effort
the balmers and quillen also supported
proposition
25 which would have replaced the state's
cash bail system with a risk-based
algorithm
they gave 6 million and 750 thousand
dollars respectively to the effort
which failed